i want to explain the best
way to get rid of acne scars
vitamin e oil if you have scarring from acne like
i did i had really bad acne in high school and i
wish i would have known what i know now back then
because acne is so easy to get rid of if you know
how for those of you that are watching that have
acne i put a link down below for that but this
video is primarily on the scarring that can occur
after you get acne if you're going to use vitamin
e oil on your face i would highly recommend
going with some organic brand hexane free
go high quality now i don't have any brand that i
recommend you're going to have to do that research
but vitamin e has a really significant effect
on fibrosis breaking down scar tissue now the
studies that i looked at relate more for cirrhosis
of the liver but i have personally observed quite
a few people experience positive results using
vitamin e on their scars including acne scars
because vitamin e is a very powerful antioxidant
it's fat soluble so it goes into the skin
it's an anti-inflammatory it can break down scar
tissue it can even help certain wrinkles on your
skin so this is what i recommend doing i would
take some vitamin e rub it into the skin for about
one or two minutes right before you go to bed i
would do that every single night for about two to
three weeks and you should see some breakdown
of that scar tissue now if you combine this
with healthy keto and intermittent fasting and
periodic prolonged fasting i think you're going
to even get better results because if you're
consuming a lot of carbs in your diet that
is going to block the effect of vitamin e and
it's going to make your skin age a lot faster
when you do fasting especially prolonged fasting
your body goes through this thing called autophagy
where you're recycling old damaged protein so the
body will start to clear out the old dead cells
and replace it with the new so it's a really good
anti-aging action now when you do prolong fasting
i would suggest you do this every two weeks or
each month where you're fasting for at least 72
hours even longer to see the maximum benefit for
more information on that i put a link down below
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as
smooth i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to answer
everyone's call but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help